piss pott worte die so sind ilsebill
finde ich ist ein grauenhafter name ja
sie auch eine grauenhafte person das ist
also entweder du bist asse binden der
fischer und seine frau diesjährige wie
folgt der fischer zieht einem boot aus
dem meer und der bus sagte ihm ich bin
eigentlich ein verwunschener prinz und
der fischer sagt ich werde doch keinen
fisch am haken behalten der sprechen
kann und setzt ihn wieder ins meer
dann geht er nach hause er wohnt in
einem sogenannten piss pott mit seiner
frau ilse bilden und dann sagt ilsebill
du hast gar nichts gefangen und dann
sagt der fischer doch ich habe diesen
gut gefangen war ein verwunschener prinz
aber die habe ich ja wieder freigelassen
sagte bist du wahnsinnig du musst sofort
wieder zurückgehen ich will ein größeres
achtet mal darauf wie philipp das so
zählen
du bist asse bild der fischer der bin
ich da geht dann zurück und sagt meine
frau die ilsebill will nicht so dass ich
wohl so ist es nämlich bei dem fischer
ist es unglaublich peinlichen auch
isabell fischer denkt genau und jetzt
muss ich schon wieder dahin geben weil
es nämlich nicht zufrieden mit dem
großen haus dann will sie nämlich im
schloss der könig königin sein dann wäre
sie kaiserin seien ja das ist eben auch
schon ein sehr problematisch der papst
sein oder
und da gott und dann wo findet sie sich
wieder im spot ich finde dieses mädchen
ist großartig weil hier nicht von
zauberern oder hexen oder feen die rede
ist sondern von einer paarbeziehung
zunächst will sie ja noch die besseren
häuser für sie als paar aber dann wie du
schon gesagt hast sie will dann kaiserin
werden und päpste der fischer spielt gar
keine rolle so noch selber geringer der
nachricht es gibt eine ganz interessante
art therapeutische interpretation der
fischer ist eigentlich mitverantwortlich
weil er sich der unzufriedenheit seiner
frau gar nicht stellt sondern immer nur
schnell ihre materiellen bedürfnisse
befriedigt ohne wirklich zu fragen was
ist der grund für diese pilz unbehagen
genau was dieses märchen auf sagt ist
dass weder das kann eigentlich auch nur
eine ilsebill sein deren mann zufällig
einen fisch gefangen hat mich hat das
immer raus stört warum ich finde diese
ganzen worte so unglaublich hässlich
ilsebill finde ich ist ein grauenhafter
name spot der fud ständig solche
komischen worte die so
ich mag lieber märchen die mich so
platzen
du kannst es nicht als rabiat das ist
ein reines normal ja es ist ein psycho
märchen ja ich mag lieber märchen die wo
die leute in den ofen geschoben werden
du magst du lieber physische gewalt okay
für mich waren märchen immer auch eine
schule der moral deswegen weiß ich sehe
auch einen ganz moralisch ließen das
heißt eine maßlos in deinen ansprüchen
sondern hast du was daraus gelernt oder
was ja immer wenn ich denke will ich
vielleicht noch dieses oder jenes kommt
mir sofort ilsebill in den sinn und ich
denke so nein bin ich mal jemanden
nichts geschrieben was ich genau das ist
die moral dieser geschichte von der
geschichte an der eltern werde ich dich
jetzt ein paar mal dran erinnern ich
bitte da wochen vor weihnachten
[Musik]